the average person checks email 74 times  a day and switches tasks on their  computer  566 times a day researchers at USC have  found they're studying teenagers who are  on social media while they're talking to  their friends or they're doing homework  and two years down the road they are  less creative and imaginative about  their own personal Futures and about  solving societal problems so the next  time you go to check your phone ask  yourself what am I really looking for  because if it's to check email that's  fine do it and be done but if it's to  distract yourself from doing the hard  work that comes with deeper thinking  take a break stare out the window and  know that by doing nothing you are  actually being your most productive and  creative self it might feel weird and  uncomfortable at first but boredom truly  can lead to brilliance